Lance tomorrow author of evil where'd
you get an idea about writing a book on
that subject well about ten years ago
I'd done a cover for that cover story
for Time magazine on the subject of evil
and I find that over a period of years
for time I've written dozens of essays
that had to do with wrestling with the
question of evil one kind or another
Dunblane Scotland they did a guy who
broke into a Grammar School there and
shot thirteen or fourteen little
schoolchildren many different subject
give me in a big historical subject and
also individual cases of pathology and
so on and it's a subject that's
interested me for a long time and I did
it twelve years ago for time and I've
just I have been meaning to turn it into
a book and kind of collect my thoughts
about it so this is the result did you
really write a hundred and fifty cover
stories although make more than that and
really nice I mean yeah you know I
stopped counting I was there long
contribute to the magazine but but you
know I was there on the staff for a long
long time
and my first one was the the Detroit
riots of 1967 and I had joined the staff
in 65 and so I went through you know the
68 campaign and the you know all of the
late 60s in Chicago Convention and all
of that stuff so I mean they just added
up I wasn't really counting but I was
sort of appalled when I when I saw how
I've been spending by the time but it
was great but how long you've been
teaching and where I teach in the
University Professors program at Boston
University which is sort of a small
College inside the
this very large University and I also
teach in their College of communications
and I've been there for seven years you
open up this it's a small book it's not
one of those majors it's about 90,000
where it's something like that with a
story about going on ron reagan's not
ronald reagan ron reagan television show
what's what was that all about well Ron
Reagan the president's son who seems
very little like his father although in
some subtle ways he is like him but had
a show had a had a talk show at that
point and he they wanted to do a thing
about evil so they invited me and a
woman from the San Francisco Church of
Satan and and a theologian to talk about
evil and I start out with it because it
it struck me one as rather funny and I
didn't want to start a book about evil
in two as it's heavy enough it's it's
it's heavy going and in a lot of my
purpose in this book was among other
things to tell a lot of stories evil is
always a story anyway but I didn't want
to get too theoretical about evil a to
theological or philosophical or
political I'm not a trained theologian
I'm not a trained philosopher and I
wanted to see it a lot through stories
and so I did that and this particular
story just struck me as as funny in a
way of delineating my attitude toward
evil from what was what was funny about
oh well I thought I found it hysterical
that over here with with Ron Reagan the
the the young woman from the Church of
Satan was wearing a leather miniskirt a
black leather miniskirt and she thought
that I was hopeless on the subject of
evil because I somehow didn't appreciate
evil in the terms in which it should be
appreciated
I was retrograde I was I was much too
conventional about evil and I'm not
quite sure what her take was but she was
thinking out of the box you know she was
trying to she was inventing new norms
for evil and new you know excitements
around the will and it one of the
reasons I mentioned it will was that it
there was a tendency for a long that has
been for quite a long while but to
regard evil as prey fly fulfill onic a
kind of edible gesture against authority
and and kind of sassy and and comes he
comes out of the Romantic tradition it
comes out of the 60s and the the channel
and challenging of authority in the 60s
and I wanted to contrast that with my
view of evil which is a possibly more
conventional but simply regards evil is
something really bad and I think the
evidence is there to support that what
was your reaction when the president
gave his speech on the access of me
access of you well I understand his
political reasons for doing it and his
so to speak diplomatic reasons I think
he wanted I thought it was in in some
ways a an interesting thing for him to
have done in the same way that Ronald
Reagan's talking about the evil empire
was I think he meant to signal to a lot
of people who including al Qaeda and and
Saddam Hussein and so on and North Korea
and Iran that he was willing to be that
here was an American who was willing to
talk in black-and-white terms in
fundamentalist terms in categorical
terms
and then to be as brutal as they were
willing to be and I think he and and I
think there was a there was a good deal
of art in that because coming at the end
of the Clinton administration and so on
weather was there really was a tendency
to think of the United States as big fat
rich and unwilling to to be serious
about opposing this kind of stuff and
terrorism and so on and you know bombing
tents and in or vacated camps in
Afghanistan and so on and I think that
that was that was his intent I think he
wanted to to bring the to the to signal
that he was moving to a different plane
and that he was very very serious and
there's no more serious term than Evel
Knievel's possibly the the strongest
term in the language and most powerful
term in the language and one of the most
difficult to get a handle on it's one of
the most difficult to define it is an
extremely dangerous term and has been
used to great to cause great evil
witness Hitler's use of the word evil
when he described Jews as evil so it's a
very dangerous term but I think his his
purpose there was to signal that he was
moving to a to a new plane I you know
almost want to give one of those
warnings to the audience they may want
to turn their television set down based
on what I'm about to read because this
isn't you know as you say that a lot of
stories in here I'm just gonna read and
have you tell the story around it
because it does get your attention
rape bonded the men in atrocity some
Serb men forced Muslim men to use their
teeth to castrate their own sons and the
sons to castrate their fathers you know
is that
a true you know I mean this is lengthy
these were news accounts coming out of
the of the I was in in Bosnia in 92 I
guess in late 92 for for a Brigitte and
fairly brief visit but this was this
came out of the I forget whether it was
Reverend Itza or it was so it was one of
the I can't I can't cite the exact place
that I got that but it was this is a
this is a that particular awfulness is
not unfamiliar and as a you know as an
atrocity there were a awful thing that
the the in in Bosnia the the behavior
was it was it's a very it struck me at
that time as an extremely evil place it
struck me as an atmosphere of evil had
descended upon this place and and I had
a palpable sense that they were that
people were doing terrible things and
these were stories that one heard now
you went was others who'd you go with
and why'd you go to well Elie Wiesel was
was going over to as a sort of observer
to try to look at the situation and to
bring his moral presence to bear and to
try to well primarily to see what was
going on but I think also to try to
influence what was going on we talked to
Kurata Chand Milosevic we went to a
prison camp up in the hills we were in
Sarajevo for for a bit and so that was
the that was the that was what that was
about Abe Rosenthal was there from the
New York Times or some a few friends of
Ali's were there two or three
what was the Milosevic meeting like
well he said he was a boat boat with
both Milosevic and Kurata there's this
elaborate air of denial there was this
elaborate air of innocence and denial
and the most an interesting thing to me
was the air of victimhood the Serb air
of that we are the victims they were
they were portraying themselves as
victims and you see it is they who are
doing it to us we are not we are victims
of their atrocity and of course in that
part of the world and there is a
terrific an awful dynamic of tit-for-tat
down the down the ages with between the
Croatians and the Serbs and the Muslims
and so on there's a there are
retaliatory reciprocal atrocities going
on or or you know
periodically over over a long period of
time when I arrived in my hotel in
Belgrade not 10 minutes passed before a
brown envelope was pushed under my my
room the door of my room and I opened up
this this large envelope and found a
fairly thick stack of eight by ten
glossy photographs of atrocities of a
hideous atrocity and they were they
purported to be crimes committed against
the Serbs by Muslims it was difficult to
tell because of the it was difficult to
I mean all you saw was there were these
awful pictures but this was this was the
Balkan press kit I mean this was you
know welcome to the territory and it was
an awful place how did you approach this
you have 34 chapters there relatively
short and as you say stories how do you
keep it all together around one word
evil well I was I was looking at trying
to look at different aspects of evil and
evil it has me as a very elusive term
and you turn it around in your hand
you see it from different angles so so I
was trying to to tell stories that I
thought illuminated different aspects of
it evil has a quality of sleight of hand
about it sort of now you see it now you
don't and I wanted to try to capture
that and and also as I say I think it's
important to to tell stories and to
discuss the stories because it it always
in acts itself through a story outfits
was a story Cambodia was a story Rwanda
was a story and Dunblane was a story
about the story of your son's classmate
Japanese yeah yeah that was a girl set
the whole thing where's your son how old
was he
well my son was what sixteen seventeen
and and he was in a in a in a school up
on the Upper East Side of Manhattan and
a girl in the school and some other guy
were they were out in Central Park
drinking beer and they fell in with this
other guy and they they murdered him and
threw his body they disemboweled him and
and threw his body in the Central Park
Lake and there was it was fairly
sensational case of a few years ago and
and I asked my son about this girl and
he said well we we knew she was trouble
we knew there was something you know
disturbed there but we didn't have any
idea of you know that it could go to
that but it was one of those cases very
difficult to but it's it's so often with
with cases of that kind where where you
you feel a presence of evil you feel you
know and say well she's a troubled child
and she you know but nevertheless the
result is evil and the I mean it's a
it's a there's something inexplicable
about that I mean evil is a word we use
when we
in situations like that I think when it
seems a as they say of motiveless
malignity there's something deeply
disturbing about that that kind of act
but we see that all the time you know
the King brothers as two teenage kids
who beat their father to death with a
with an aluminum baseball bat
not too long ago the two kids up at
Dartmouth in New Hampshire who who
murdered the Dartmouth professors boys
said they were conducting an
environmental survey they knocked on the
door you know as a project for the
school and once inside they drew hunting
knives and murdered the professor's
stabbing them repeatedly even stabbing
them in the face did they ever find do
they ever catch them and fell sure yeah
they got him and they tried him and they
say why they did it I believe that they
were trying to they had some one version
was that they had some idea of a
financing a trip to Australia you know
sort of like Huck and Tom lighting out
for the territory I mean something as as
strange is that or is it explicitly very
difficult to where did you grow up in
your life where were you born
I grew I was born in Philadelphia but my
parents were both journalists and they
were in Washington DC so I grew up here
in Washington and your father's a big
name in the past and politics in general
well he he he was at The Saturday
Evening Post when I was a little kid in
Washington and he bought a humara yes
and then he he got into politics he went
to work for Senator Irving Ives of New
York and then senator Kenneth Keating
and then after that he went to work for
Nelson Rockefeller when Rockefeller was
running for his first term in the late
50s and he stayed with Rockefeller until
Rockefeller died and in fact my my
father announced Rockefellers I mean met
the press after Rock though his death
and and reported it to the press on the
only time I ever knew him to lie and for
those who haven't paid attention what
are you talking about you mean in that
July yes oh well the lie was that Mayor
Rockefeller died in the company of his
mistress and on in in a townhouse on
54th Street and my father in the in an
effort to spare mrs. Rockefeller
embarrassment because they were all
there at Lenox Hill Hospital late at
night and mrs. Rockefeller was there and
so was the young woman and my father in
an effort to despair mrs. Rockefeller
concocted the truly preposterous story
that Nelson had been up in his in his
office in Rockefeller Center working on
his art books like a medieval monk
illuminated manuscripts in his in his
office he did that that of course sprang
a leak in about a day because the
ambulance drivers in the cop said no
wait a minute it's just not foot this is
not what happened
one shouldn't laugh about it but at any
case it was it was even my father was
deeply upset about it for a long time
because we you know he was very fond of
Rockefeller and didn't you read a book
about it I wrote a book called the chief
yeah in the mid-80s and it was about my
father and about
and I mentioned this stuff in in that
book as well there's a little reference
in your book on evil to being a pageboy
in the United States Senate when you
were around 13 years old yeah what was
that like for you ma'am it was wonderful
and fascinating it was one of the great
experiences of my life I was only I was
you know 13 that I found it absolutely
fascinating and it introduced me to that
didn't introduce me but I was I was
running errands for Joe McCarthy John
Kennedy Hubert Humphrey Lyndon Johnson
Robert Taft and this is this whole array
of characters and so as I watched them
very closely for I did it two summers
once on the Republican side once on the
Democratic side and it was wonderful I
found it absolutely fascinating any
lasting impressions from that experience
oh sure I mean many many impressions of
the personalities and the characters
there were there is a it was when
Kennedy walked into that Senate chamber
and hidden in those and I was at a time
of he was he was you know terribly ill
with his back and so on he was on
crutches and so on
but it was very interesting that it was
very interesting to me to watch the to
study the personality character the way
that people reacted to these characters
and Kennedy everybody all the Senators
and so on and they you know a roomful of
narcissists you know a prima donnas and
so on but when he walked in in the the
the doors at the top of the center aisle
every pair of eyes turned to Kenya this
is the freshman senator from
Massachusetts Saltonstall was they saw
my Jackie and he's not not talking about
Jack Kennedy young yeah oh this is the
his brothers were you know but it was a
fascinating land and Johnson was was
fascinating to watch Bobby Baker was my
boss you know who was Lyndon Johnson's
protege and still alive yeah you know he
was he was very interesting
I mean he was he was good he was a good
boss and he did so he told very funny
stories and he was always telling
Kennedy stories but you know seeing
Kennedy with some blond on F Street that
the you know over the weekend or
something like that Kennedy wasn't
married at that point but I found it
wonderful to look at look at the
senators I love the Senate and I and I
am fascinated by a particularly by I'd
always I've always wanted to write a
book about the Senate at that time
Robert Caro got it very well in his in
his latest book on Johnson he was I was
it was great nostalgia for me because
Caro describes every leather couch and
the sofa and in the cloakroom in the
Democratic cloakroom and the bank of
telephones and where the they all drank
for some reason when they weren't
drinking clear alcoholic fluids they
would trade they were all drank White
Rock soda water so bill Nolan of
California for example would always you
know snap his hands for me and I'd run
off turn it's a White Rock and you can
run up to the cloakroom and get him up
get him a thing of white Crockett Lyndon
would send him Johnson would send you
for vanilla ice cream a lot to go down
to the side race downstairs to the
Senate dining room and bring him a dish
of vanilla ice cream on the on the floor
but it was it was what for a kid you
know I'm just kidding quite quite young
I was barely I think I was underage the
first summer I was 12 but they kind of
let me let me in and so for a kid of
that age it was I was just knocked out
we mentioned and both of me when we
started and then again we referring to
the Senate stories
you can you you remember I mean you've
obviously told a lot of stories you know
when that very thing interested you
telling stories hearing stories yeah I
I'm sorry I didn't quite get what you
well you obviously enjoy writing about
telling stories yeah you say that yes
book is a series of stories yeah when
did you find yourself getting interested
in that kind of work yeah my mind I've
always been interested in that I've my
mind my parents were both writers and
I've always I've never had the slightest
doubt that that's what I wanted to do
and I think I've always liked that like
storytelling in in this book you
mentioned Hannah Arendt if that's the
way I've heard it pronounced several
ways is that the way you I say Hana R
Arendt yeah Eichmann in Jerusalem why
but you mentioned her several times what
is it about her I was I was you know she
wrote that famous book called Eichmann
in Jerusalem in in the early 60s about
the Eichmann trial and she her subtitle
was the banality of evil and I always
thought she was somewhat dissatisfied
with the term banality and I I think
that the term banality it doesn't quite
do it because I what did what she I
think she should have said was the
ordinariness the the the flat
ordinariness of evil but in any case I
was interested in something that she got
into a an argument with the great
scholar of Jewish mysticism Gershom
Scholem
who objected to the book on on several
grounds but in any case she wrote a very
interesting letter to him sometime after
Eichmann in Jerusalem list was published
and she said I no longer believe in
radical evil i no longer believe that
evil is profound in the sort of
traditional sense but rather she think
that she thought it was
shallow and lethal but very very deadly
and capable of tremendous destruction
but like a fungus something like a
fungus and I and so the reason that I
that I talked about her to some extent
has to do with language and metaphor how
do you conceive of evil evil evolves
evil changes it's very adaptable and it
ended it it shapes itself to the
configuration of the time and the
technology and so on but there's always
a question of how to talk about it what
language you use what metaphors you use
the Prince of Darkness is an essentially
medieval metaphor it's a monarchical
metaphor it arises out of a medieval
model of society Milton's Satan and
Milton's Lucifer in Paradise Lost is
along that same model a sort of heroic
satanic figure in rebellion against God
and and a not unattractive rebellion not
entirely unattractive rebellious been
said a million times that that Milton's
Lucifer is more interesting than his God
it got more character personnel and just
more interesting figure and indeed a lot
of people think evil is a lot more
interesting than good but in any case
there's the minar kacal they these sort
of fierce individualized mephistopheles
the dr. Faustus kind of evil but our
Hannah Arendt is going to a to a
different metaphor altogether and she's
saying fungus disease infection which
takes away from it that kind of romantic
you know heroic defiance non survey on
I will not serve you know Lucifer says
non survey um I will not sir I will not
you know I would so that that has that's
heroic that's you know the Declaration
of sort of doomed independence or
something like that well she's saying
and I'm fungus you know I look at Sierra
Leone where the these rebel soldiers are
chopping off the the hands of ten arms
of children this is not a heroic this is
not lucid mephistopheles or Lucifer and
on survey um this is a fungus this is a
you know the filthy kind of evil and
then or that Cambodia we're awful awful
things of that kind or or the business
you mentioned earlier about the Bosnia
this is this is not or American slavery
the worst depredations of American
slavery yeah so I I think that she
located in that language a very
important aspect of evil and and I do
mention I go back to her periodically
partly also because it's a generational
thing and it's also well it's a
twentieth-century thing but Auschwitz is
the baseline the the the the final
solution the the hitlerism and and its
attempt to exterminate the Jews of
Europe is kind of the baseline of of
evil in or I suppose it still is but in
any case it certainly was the beginning
of my moral education I mean I I have
always been you know from from the time
I was a child been indelibly aware of
the the first films that came out of the
camps in 1945 of the corpses and the and
the near the people who were near dead
and so on and so that
was kind of the formation of my it was
the beginning of my trying to think
about this I am for so many other people
too I thought it might be interesting
for audience to hear that the words of
heinrich himmler i you i can its page
177 do you want to read him go home
eatery my dad to have you do house you
only because that that last you
obviously felt it was important enough
to put it in there
well himmler was you know running the
running the SS and he was he was one of
great hitler's is this was on october
3rd of 1943 himmler this was as I say a
Heinrich Himmler in a sort of mission
statement to his SS an amazingly candid
document the most murderous evil couched
in terms curiously ingenuous and weirdly
self-congratulatory laid out the case
for the well for his position he says
and this is this is Himmler speaking he
says our basic principle must be
absolute for the SS man we must be
honest decent loyal and comradely to
members of our own blood and to nobody
else what happens to the Russians what
happens to the Czechs is a matter of
total indifference to me what there is
among the nations in the way of good
blood of our kind good blood of our kind
we will take for ourselves if necessary
by kidnapping their children and raising
them among us whether the other nations
live in prosperity or croak from hunger
interests me only insofar as we need
them for slaves for our culture
otherwise it does not interest me
whether 10,000 Russian females dropped
from exhaustion while building an
anti-tank ditch interests me only
insofar as the anti-tank ditch gets
finished for Germany's sake we shall
never be brutal and heartless where it
is not necessary
obviously not we Germans the only people
in the world who have a decent attitude
toward animals
we'll also take a decent attitude toward
these humanum animals but it is a crime
against our own blood to worry about
them and to give them ideals that will
make it still harder for our sons and
grandsons to cope with them our concern
our duty is to our own people and our
blood toward everything else we can be
indifferent
I wish the SS to take this attitude in
confronting the problem of all alien non
Germanic peoples especially the Russians
all else is just soap bubbles prose
style how important was he well he was
when he was one of the you know central
figures in the in Hitler circle and he
certainly was a that that the the reason
I quoted that at such length is that
that that does they seemed to me the
absolute distillation of the attitude
from which evil so often proceeds which
is the attitude that only we are of any
importance everyone else is subhuman not
human not not not to be you know not not
to be accorded any of the consideration
that one gives to a human being and once
you get that and you see it all over the
world all the time but this is a
particularly bald chilling statement of
it have you ever met anybody like that
sure yeah I mean racists of one kind or
another I think just regard you know I
mean the Middle East you I've met
I've met Arabs who spoke of Jews that
way and I'm just I had to say I've met
some Jews who spoke a coupling in Hebron
one time I met a real fanatical guy who
you know would talked in those terms
about Arabs and down south you I mean
it's it I think don't you think it's a
pretty pretty universe I just won
everyone rarely sees it as as clearly
stated as as this you mentioned early in
your book about Harry Truman sitting
next to Joseph Stalin yeah when you
think back on that you think he had any
any idea I don't think I think Truman
was kind of naive about Uncle Joe and of
course there was the dead well a lot of
people were but but it wasn't I mean
this was this was late in the game the
Moscow trials and they meant many of his
crimes were known I mean his crimes were
just absolutely monstrous and and many
of them were known the to say decimation
doesn't cover it the you know the the
mass slaughters of his of the poets and
scientists and even his generals his
soldiers it you know they was and and
that that had begun to come out you know
in the late 30s the Moscow trial said we
went 36 37 and then the and then most
intelligent American communists said oh
my god
you know if that's what it's all about
let me out of here so when Harry Truman
dropped the two bombs was that evil well
I hadn't herma and yes I think I think
that's one of the most interesting that
leads one into an absolutely I mean
leave aside Nagasaki for a minute and
just talk about Hiroshima because I
think they in some ways they're slightly
different calculations but if you're
talking about Hiroshima
do you mean you're talking about 110,000
120,000 deaths in the I believe in the
in the initial thing and of course there
were a lot of radiation and sickness
deaths later but there is this grisly
arithmetic this awful calculation that
has been going on ever since a
hypothetical calculation of how many
American soldiers would have died in an
invasion of the home islands and the the
estimates of that would go from I
suppose half a million to up to a
million or something like that and this
doesn't count the number of Japanese who
would be killed in a what would would
surely have been a somewhat fanatical
defense or a an obdurate defense of of
the home islands so if you were if you I
mean are you reduced to this kind of
arithmetic this kind of grisly business
where you say well we would have lost a
lot more and the Japanese would have
lost a lot more therefore Truman was
justified in in in dropping that bomb
and then there are all sorts of of other
in people try to think of it as well
could could you have dropped a
demonstration bomb well I don't think we
had I don't think we had the bombs
available I think it was a sense of
urgency about using that but but there
was a well as it's an old argument and
people know these these considerations
but as to whether it was evil I myself
am mmm really not certain what to say
about it and and it I try to go into the
book about and talk about necessary evil
permissible evil what is what is
permissible evil what is a people like
Paul Fussell you know Paul Fussell the
wonderful the writer who did the Great
War in modern memory was I believe on
his way to I mean he would have been
among the troops thrown up against the
home islands I believe William
Manchester if I'm not mistaken there
were an awful lot of American troops who
were very very grateful who were on
their way from the European theater to
the Pacific to participate in the
invasion
so I myself am am puzzled about it some
of the one thing that I try to point out
in my book and one of the reasons that I
did it as I did it was that very often
it's you know it's one one shouldn't be
too categoricals sometimes about you
know it's evil evil is such an absolute
word that it invites a certain dogmatism
but very often you you have to it leads
you into a terrible maze and and you
it's it's sometimes you can't be
categorical I don't know different you
know good people on either side can can
differ on that abortion is another
extremely I mean I you know the taking
of the taking of you know and then you
get into a quest you get into the
parsing just as is with Hiroshima you
have to parse casualties weigh this
against this so you go into abortion and
then you you say well when exactly do
you say that life begins when precisely
so up to what point would you say it's
permissible or would you say no no the
instant of conception and so you get
into these these much more difficult I I
think anybody who's too dogmatic about
evil
is is headed for trouble I also think
that you know there's I say at one point
that I in trying to sense evil it might
be useful to think of Justice Potter
Stewart famous line about pornography I
know it when I see it okay we're having
most of us think we know evil when we
see it or we we feel it maybe see it as
you just sort of sense it and feel it
and some but unfortunately you know a
lot of people have thought they saw evil
or sensed evil and they wind up you know
burning innocent girls as witches or in
the in the case of Germany and the Third
Reich you know setting up trying to
exterminate people whom they describe as
Hitler described as evil and so and you
know the method of evil is so often to
describe the other as evil so if you if
you can persuade people and lynch mobs
rockwork this way if you if you're
running a lynch mob and people are led
to to a lynch mob mentality and so on
you could say well let these are rapists
these evil these you know it got it
string him up so you have an evil deed
committed to punish perhaps the fantasy
of an evil deed as you know with 34
chapters each one brings on a new story
I just wanted to read I think the best
way to treat this is read chapter 25 I
want to read the first pair evil subject
to boredom is forever concocting the
delicacies and refinements travelers in
China have reported the cultish gourmets
ritual of dining upon the brains of a
live monkey that has been imprisoned in
mobile below the center of the dining
table the top of its head exposed
through a round hole on the table the
top of the skull is then removed and the
diners used their chopsticks to dine
upon morsels of the monkey's brain the
connoisseurs pleasure made more
exquisite presumably
by the exoticism of the cruelty and the
onstage fatality at the table
is it an evil pleasure you asked where
did you find that one
oh that particular thing monkey your
chapter is heading gourmets and monkey
brains that rooster I mean you actually
do well it is that that has been that
the travelers have have reported that
from time to time I got that from a
wonderful book a wonderful writer named
Lila Hadley loose who who wrote a book
in the late 50s called give me the world
and she described that but that's I
think I believe that that has some and
she was she was in in a traveling around
Asia and so on and and described this
encounter but I believe that this has
been mentioned in you know more than a
few what were you getting at I'm sorry
what were you getting at in the chapter
what was your point well I think partly
just the the there is a sadistic or
there is a evil evil very often takes
pleasure in the gratuitous infliction of
of pain its its sadistic impulse and in
and it's the gratuitousness or the it's
the it's the exercise of power and it's
and and a certain exoticism I I think
that I think of the Roman emperors
racking their brains you know and or at
least you know in sweet own astray
Tonia's version of of them for example
and the
Tiberius or Caligula or some of the
other Romans and the extremely fancy and
decadent pleasures that they divide and
sadistic pleasures that the I won't even
go into the so awful but but being able
to execute somebody peremptorily on a
whim
it's the whims Cala T of the enemy
there's an element of whim
you know Stalin used to have dinners
that went on all night with his circle
and then there would be guests and so
there would be a tremendous amount of
drinking and these guys would be you
know and they felt they had to keep up
with the drinking and they would be
drunk and terrified at the same time
very often and sometimes in the morning
late the KGB are I guess I guess then it
was the NKVD would simply take a guy out
enigmatic lay no evident reason and he
would disappear obviously shot or sent
to Siberia but this is a this a you know
power it's an it is often has to do with
the power or the infliction of fear and
so on this is this is something somewhat
different from what you started asking
about that but it's that it's that
quality and I was trying to get at that
quality of them
a certain exquisiteness of malice that
you know I mean it's really disgusting
but what was your reaction to your cover
story on evil for Time magazine we've
got a deluge of mail it got a huge
amount of mail how did it compare with
others I mean what's been the biggest
reaction to all your hundreds of how
would you say cut at least that was the
debate that was the biggest that was the
biggest I think I I'm not dead sure
about this but I think that was the most
letters they've gotten what would a many
- what were they excited well they were
they were a mixed bag they were I'm
trying to remember it was a while ago
but various comments and a lot of
fundamentalist Christians wrote in to
take issue with this or that but it's
the the the the cover story sort of
looked at it from different angles so it
wasn't I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't trying
to lay down a line as indeed I'm not
doing so in this book either I'm not
trying to lay down up you know this is
because I don't I don't think you can do
that I think it's too mysterious a
subject and but I'm trying to remember
what they but do you want the focus of
those letters was it was if they were
scattered they were mixed when when you
wrote the cover stories did you feel
power that's an interesting question no
I mean I mean you would sit at your desk
on a Friday afternoon pounding out a
cover story and then all of a sudden
Monday boom that's very interesting
question what part of the fun of of
working was it was great to work for
time in part because of the satisfaction
that you need to write something and
write a write a big piece like that and
sure enough but but when you're when
you're putting that together you don't
feel power you feel all sorts of other
things like panic and had
pressure and I was really thinking after
that I mean you know you're good a
magazine hits the stands on Monday and
you see your work and it's you do it
weekend letting me a good deal of
satisfaction I mean you know it was it
was very satisfying to communicate with
times audience on a in such a way and it
yeah but I haven't power I don't I don't
think I thought of it exactly its power
how many years did you write for time
well I I still write for them but I was
I'm now in contract with them rather
than on the staff but I was from from
1965 to 1996 when I when I took early
retirement and went on contract with
them teaching it Boston universe and
then a that I started teaching at Boston
University in addition to doing these
other things do you when you write is
there your own techniques is there any
place especially you like to write or
time of day I'd love to write in the
morning and I used to be years ago when
I smoked a lot I could the nicotine
would keep me up all night and I could
do that and but I find the best time for
me is 7 7 in the morning through till
lunchtime and I find my I'm freshest
then and that's that's when I like to
ride place well I have a great study
where I like to write and but I
sometimes I like to write some someplace
said there was a period in my life when
I would I would ride buses in Subway's
and write and write on the subway you
know with it with a pad and pencil
because there was something about the
anonymity or they or the the jostle I
David there was something about having
all that motion around me and it kind of
I don't know what it must have released
some sort of nervous energy in me but I
like to do that I could I can write
almost anywhere I mean I was I was
trained as a I was when I worked for the
Washington star many years ago as a
reporter it's the paper is now do
but it's an afternoon papers so we would
have to cover a story and then throw a
dime as it was then a dime into the
public telephone and you know ten
minutes to deadline you have a notebook
and a telephone just dictate the story
straight into the into the phone it's
great training for clarity of
composition it really is I mean sir I
would just and it was great because Carl
Bernstein and I were dictation is
together on the star on the Washington
star so sometimes I'd be dictating to
Carl or he'd be dictating to me and it's
it's an interesting way to to learn how
to write so I've always been pretty good
on deadlines as a result as a matter of
fact I sometimes think I need deadlines
you know in a journalistic way and that
I don't get myself quite organized until
until somebody is threatening my life
the who's the fellow that you donate
mean dedicate the book to Stefan can for
Stefan can't for you know who is he he's
a very dear old friend from many years
at time he's the author most recently of
a ball of fire which is a it's a lovely
book about Lucille Ball he wrote a
terrific biography of Groucho Marx a few
years ago he's written a number of other
books he was four years the books editor
of Time magazine and before that he was
the movie critic and he's he's a
wonderful guy and he's these and he's an
old friend there's not much time but I'd
like to have you tell the story of the
art history department at an Ivy League
university yeah that was in a minute
tell us as much as you can
well this was this was an instance of a
of the sort of office malice or just the
minor kind of in and it was difficult to
tell whether it it arose to the level of
evil or not but there was an AM in a
department of a university
a woman a very bright young woman who
had a doctorate and was supporting a
husband who also had a doctorate but was
unemployed and a couple of kids and so
on and the department chairman began
having a an affair were they with a
different woman and other woman in the
in the department and for some reason
this woman with whom the chairman was
having an affair took some sort of
malicious dislike to the the woman that
I'm speaking of the and and so it was an
art history department and so one day
sent her an email saying oh by the way
who was so-and-so unnamed a fairly
well-known 19th century American Hudson
River School artists and the the woman
thought it was a perfectly obvious
question but just went to Google typed
in the artist name got a decent little
summary of this artist biography and
this is Robert Cole yeah and and and
just sent it right by return email to
the woman and so the the first woman
made a copy of that went to Google found
the article from which the other woman
had taken printed them both up and
lodged a charge of plagiarism against
the woman who had done her the favor of
sending this little article and the
result was that this was in her file it
was it caused all sorts of trouble it
caused terrible personal difficulties
you know physical stress and and and
that she survived it but but at
considerable cost and it was him and
they had to hire a lawyer file a suit to
to have it removed from her jacket you
know her personnel file so it I was the
reason I introduced it was that it was
it was you know it's a it's an interest
we all are familiar with some case
similar case I think of it but it again
the gratuitousness of it it's a small
thing but causing real anguish and real
the threat to to the this family's
livelihood because the the husband
wasn't working woman needed her job in
order to support her children and their
family and it struck me that it that it
it had it was in the neighborhood of
something it was an evil impulse and it
interested me for that reason next book
I'm working on a thing about 1948 and
about Kennedy Johnson and Nixon as young
men
so thank you Lance Morrow has been our
guest the cover of his current book is
called evil and investigation and we
thank you for joining us thank you